jane foster's wielding the magical
hammer mjolnir but she's also sporting
some impressive arm muscles are those
guns connected to mjolnir's return and
how did jane get her newly jacked hands
on thor's old hammer anyway
warning spoilers ahead for thor love and
thunder
directed by taika ytt thor 11 thunder
has finally hit theaters complete with a
brand new villain numerous references to
mythology and some screaming goats the
narrative also reintroduces viewers to
dr jane foster whose presence is
instrumental in helping thor and king
valkyrie battle against an evil that
threatens the future of new asgard ever
since the first trailer dropped fans
have been clamoring to find out what
leads the astrophysicist to become
mighty thor and how she came to possess
thor's old hammer
at this point in the franchise mjolnir
is practically a character all its own
the hammer's resurrection brings about a
host of changes significantly
influencing thor's journey to
self-discovery after years of letting us
wonder thor love and thunder finally
explains why thor and jane went their
separate ways for an astrophysicist and
the god of thunder the pair managed to
build a strong foundation for a future
together everything was good for a while
but the differences in their lives
eventually drove a wedge between them as
it turns out it's not easy building a
life with someone who's always running
off to face intergalactic threats
thor couldn't cope with his fear of
losing her so he embraced the growing
distance in the relationship in the end
it was jane who pulled the plug on the
romance even if thor has trouble
admitting it sorry to hear that jane
dumped you
she didn't dump me you know
i dumped her some mutual dumping
following the events of avengers end
game thor is back to his old self with
the help of a strict workout regimen and
some quality time with the guardians of
the galaxy he hasn't seen jane in years
but that's about to change jane's life
has changed dramatically since viewers
last saw her in thor the dark world in
thor's absence she's had plenty of time
to focus on her career unfortunately
jane discovers that she has stage four
cancer and her prognosis isn't looking
good although darcy and dr selvig have
attempted to convince her to save her
energy jane has been tirelessly working
to find a way to cure herself reaching
the end of a robe jane finds herself
drawn to tales from norse mythology
although thor and the other asgardians
aren't immortal the fact cemented by
loki's death at the hands of thanos they
don't fall victim to the same frailties
that affect humans
their magic grants him a certain level
of invulnerability including super
strength and good health these aspects
of godliness intrigue jane but there's
more to it than that
thor's hammer mjolnir has always been a
conduit for this power and it calls out
to jane
flashbacks demonstrate that this is no
accident as the relationship dwindled
thor asked me olneyr to watch overchain
a magical request that has remained
intact even after all these years thor
and jane are still connected whether
they know it or not in a last-ditch
effort to cure her cancer jane travels
to new asgard which has become a major
tourist attraction after being destroyed
by hela and thor ragnarok the broken
pieces of mjolnir are on display in a
glass case since its destruction
everyone has assumed that mjolnir was
beyond repair for the relocated
asgardians the shattered relic reminds
them of where they came from and all
they face since the decimation of their
homeworld for sightseers it's the
physical embodiment of one of earth's
mightiest heroes
for jane it's her last hope for survival
a doorway to a life or her illness is a
thing of the past all this time myonir
was waiting for jane and she's more than
worthy as promised mjolnir grants jane
the powers of a god resulting in the
effortlessly cool muscled up version of
the character fans have seen in trailers
unfortunately wielding the hammer isn't
enough to save jane who dies helping
thor defeat gore the god butcher her
sacrifice has a profound effect on thor
who was finally able to accept his past
and look towards a brighter future
mjolnir in hand
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you